literally beat my brother and left him
for dead threw him out of a moving
vehicle on the side of the freeway
luckily the people that were behind the
vehicle that he got thrown out of ended
up seeing my brother and called 911
Deadliest Catch cast member Jake Harris
allegedly beaten robbed and left on the
side of the road after an altercation
his brother Josh took to Facebook to
share the news amazing I see you right
now some individuals beat him to the
point where it cracked the skull from
his forehead all the way back to where
he would be balding as an individual but
we found them city of Everett Police
Department official Erin Snell confirmed
to ETA two suspects have been arrested
my brother's doing better the cat scan
results haven't come back yet but I
talked to a little bit according to the
police news release Harris was getting a
ride home from a couple when the man
allegedly started assaulting Harris as
the woman drove Harris says he blacked
out and woke up on the side of the
highway with $2,400 missing